Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel me and my family we're here in
Japan and we're spending the next two
and a half weeks petting animals
exploring castles catching fish being
bitten by deer going to baseball games
seeing amazing sights and having a great
time
early guys
[Music]
about it
I would forget
[Music]
[Applause]
all right oh my goodness look at the
number of beds in here
[Music]
hey guys welcome to fukoga Japan
after over 24 hours of traveling we're
here you tired Tom
I'll tell you what these hotels in Japan
are so nice everything's complementary
there's no tipping and the prices and
exchange rate are awesome right now the
Ruby even comes with Pajamas the hotel
gave the kids a little gift basket and
there's like teddy bear slippers
and a little toothbrush all right let's
check out the bathroom oh look at this
shower big Japanese soaking tub
and of course high-tech toilets the seat
is heated to your body temperature and
it has various cleaning features it even
has sound effects to cover up the sounds
of farting
I can't wait to poop all right Tom let's
go get some food
all right we'll hunting gather for you
babe all right
the food in Japan is amazing and the
best part about going to restaurants
here is that they put models of the food
with the prices in front of the
restaurant
I think Mom would be interested in stuff
like that yeah that's like a beef place
that's steak look at that spaghetti with
an egg on it that's really good those
are cold soba noodles and this is cold
Ramen and this is United Sushi it's a
sweet tofu skin
right there
and you got that
below the end we hit out the convenience
store and just got something quick and
easy everyone's tired and hungry
yes little ice cream bon bons oh wow we
got cold sweet Nadi Sushi it's it's like
sweet tofu skin here just give it a
little nibble
this is a strawberry shortcake flavored
ice cream bon bon can I have one where
the weather is hot and sticky cold
buckwheat noodles with cold dipping
sauce is so fabulously refreshing
foreign
everybody it is a beautiful day here in
Fukuoka Japan and we actually got some
sleep I think it's time to go get some
breakfast
grab a tray and grab a set of toss yeah
put it on there Teriyaki and egg chicken
salad good this is like sugary it's good
why don't you grab one oh this is a milk
bun grab one of these let me grab the
lemon Danish or not that's an apple pie
you got that all right
is that good oh wish wash
all right should we go bring the food
back to Mama
we got good food that's a milk bread
it's just a really good soft bread a
croissant with filling inside here this
is like a hot dog thing that Tommy
wanted all right you're gonna try the
pocati sweat
Tom is the only one of our kids that has
been to Japan before you remember picati
Sweat Right
oh yeah it's like a sport drink but the
flavor is one that we just don't have in
the U.S this is for you this is like a
lemon turnover thing oh that's a good
apple turnover
all right we just finished up breakfast
and Nathan's super excited to poop well
Nathan are you excited yeah why I need
poo all right go for it go use the
Japanese toilet
tell us how it was
what that was seriously amazing oh look
it's got an auto clean if you leave
little poo smudgies on it the sprayer
comes out and cleans them off Jake do
you need to poop too yeah are you
excited yes I loved it
now that we got breakfast out of the way
we need to go get rail passes
we're gonna get a special rail pass that
allows us to go anywhere in Japan you
can get an unlimited two-week Nationwide
rail pass for about 70 a person it's
much much cheaper than renting a car
we're checking out the hotel will let us
store our bags in their little Locker
area and this is really common in Japan
and it's great for when you're in
between hotels you don't have to carry
your bags around all day
[Music]
we're gonna do something the family's
really excited about we are going to go
to an animal Cafe
all right guys we're gonna go to moth's
animal Cafe this is a place where people
who can't have pets come to enjoy being
around pets and animals
here this walk really slowly so you
don't scare them
see yeah
sure
[Music]
that case is so cool I love it
yeah there you go
is that cute
I think he likes me I think he likes you
Dad too
[Applause]
much
[Music]
you want to hold him
is that way cool yeah
are you having a ball
oon
that means
baby baby
look at this
and look at this one oh look Tommy
iguana
[Music]
he's very chill
oh you got a little hedgehog in there
look at that that's oh look they have
chinchillas they have the softest
forever those are the cutest little owls
nice
check it out they've got a sloth yep
that's the Japanese word for pull and
you see right
was that one of the coolest things I
loved it I love the coffee bottle
activity or any of the other activities
on our trips we'll put links with more
information down in the video
description below
really good does it oh look at these are
the Japanese
pancakes
like means like super fluffy go for it
please do look at that that looks like
this is a Berry sauce
it's like a pancake cloud
holy mackerel that disappeared I took a
school of piranhas out to lunch
that is the best omelette I have ever
had is that amazing
wow that looks amazing
it's like a Dutch baby smothered in the
gooey center of a cinnamon roll with
apple slices in it that's good
oh there's you
oh
Nathan
[Music]
look at this you can win dried squid
oh come on Thomas come on
oh Nathan David oh
[Music]
Jacob did you have fun no
okay Jacob doesn't like claw machines
apparently
all right guys we're gonna play an
arcade machine I think we can win see
all right there you go
hold on oh Dad tax
oh we got a picardi sweat I can't yeah I
can't get this is Aquarius it's a sports
drink here in Asia that's really popular
and it tastes so good on hot days
apparently this thing's a giant robot in
its head and arms and stuff will
actually move
um
all right all right guys you ready to go
to Nagasaki yeah
it says
okay how about
go stand by Tommy go
thank you
this is no one way
I know
all right we're here in the Steep
Hillside suburbs of Nagasaki
and we have a rental house down there
somewhere
all right this is the game con guys we
take our shoes off in the game con
foreign
let's check this place out
you guys like this well guys check it
out these are Samurai bows
this is a Japanese style house instead
of carpet they have tatami mats which is
woven bamboo it's harder than carpet but
softer than hardwood and you have the
sliding doors made with paper normally
though instead of western style beds
they'll just move the furniture over and
lay down futons and sleep there at night
and when you get up in the morning you
put away your futon and you move the
furniture back over all right guys we
gotta look for the bathroom first one to
find the bathroom winds
oh I found it
it's in here check it out
[Applause]
put your hands in the top of the toilet
Tom do you want to go with me to go out
and get dinner
so me and Tom are gonna go for a little
walk and get some Chinese food
yeah
the second biggest holiday in Japan is
obon where you celebrate your deceased
ancestors families all across Nagasaki
will come up into this Hillside and
shoot off fireworks and have picnics
here in the graveyard
pretty
much
yeah tell me you hit the button see that
button right there
push the button
we got ourselves Chinese food
[Music]
hold that for me
oh
sure
my guess is that was some sort of group
prayer or well-wishing because they are
doing that in front of a hospital clinic
a little late night stroll through the
cemetery
[Music]
rice
okay oh I think I forgot to buy rice
okay here is a bunch of gyozas gyozas
are from China but here in Japan they
fry them we got some Ramen another
Japanese food that came from China yeah
Mavado food here there's also another
Chinese food that's popular here in
Japan usually eaten over rice like a
curry
sweet and sour chicken something we're
familiar with in the US
Hey Jake you like that donut
good dessert you just give me one of the
little balls off it
it's like fried Mochi donut that is
that is really good even without the
rice it was a good meal
all right it's still really early in the
morning
all right gonna grab the tray I want to
get that for us it's a brownie why don't
you grab one of those
this is cream cheese spread
oh oh that's so warm as though I had to
push it out
but uh
here check these out got brownie caramel
scone this is like an orange pastry it's
got cream cheese I think you should try
this one the baked goods are still
amazing in Japan
the warm cream in that that is good
yeah and don't hey guys don't put your
slippers here in the dirty game car okay
yeah I know I'm just saying please go
outside
you ready to go see some World War II
history yes all right let's do it
okay thank you all right thank you
okay
you guys want to get an ice cream treat
this one
here yeah you got the ice is good
this is one of Becca's favorites yukimi
daifu it's little balls of ice cream
wrapped in Mochi skin
okay you guys ready yeah
it's amazing you like the Gotti Gotti
Isa
I used to eat those all the time those
are great oh you like the Yuki I love it
it's okay
did it feel nice to eat ice cream in the
shade
going straight from Alaska to
subtropical Japan has been a little hard
on Nathan is this too hot for you
all right guys the first place we're
visiting here in Nagasaki is the peace
Park as you may know the second atomic
bomb dropped in World War II fell very
close to here
about 24 years ago I lived here in
Nagasaki prefecture and after marrying
Becca we came here in 2003 as newlyweds
it's really fun to now be able to share
that with my children
here in Japan there's a tradition that
if you fold 1 000 paper cranes you get a
witch so people who wish for World Peace
will fold 1 000 paper cranes and bring
them to this park so these are from
school kids and different people around
Japan who have folded A Thousand Paper
Cranes you can see it's just strings and
strings of little tiny paper cranes this
bronze statue was erected just 10 years
after the atomic bomb leveled the city
yeah
this park is full of statues and
monuments donated from communities
around the world
this is where the atomic bomb was
dropped see that Tower
right here is the epicenter of the
atomic bomb attack
about one-third of Nagasaki was
destroyed in 150 000 people killed or
injured one thing a lot of foreigners
don't know about Nagasaki is that it was
and still is the center of Christianity
in Japan that right there is the remains
of the largest Catholic Cathedral at the
time in Japan
this was the ground level at the time of
the atomic bomb
see those are pieces of dishes those are
pieces of people's roof tiles
so this right here is the monument to
the 10 000 Koreans who were killed in
the atomic blast many of them were here
against their will leaving food water
and other offerings on the graves of
people who passed away as a tradition in
Asia and these water bottles are all
left for the spirits of those Koreans
who died here
these are all things that were found
that were melted by the blast from the
atomic bomb that's a glass bottle it's
so pretty that was a little girl's lunch
box
it's made out of cranes it's amazing
that is a lot of cranes no these ones
are already a little paper crane right
there
I'll tell you what that museum was
interesting a few of the displays were a
little bit graphic for our younger kids
but uh I'm glad we went
this is the one-legged Tori a Tory is a
gate it is a symbol of Shintoism half of
this one was blown away by the atomic
bomb
people got little origami cranes and
bottles down there
you guys hungry
yeah you guys want to get some tone cots
yeah all right let's do it
all right we're gonna go to one of
Becca's favorite restaurants yay
the chain restaurant but they serve
really good tonkots tone cots is a
Japanese version of a Portuguese version
of German schnitzel deep fried pork
cutlet with cabbage and rice oh it's
amazing
this is perfect got sesame seeds can I
smash them if you want to say somebody's
a brown noser or is kissing up you go
like this in Japanese it's a tradition
that you praise your host while you're
going and grinding the sesame seeds so
if somebody's kissing butt they say
they're grinding the sesame seeds then
you pour the cone Cod sauce in there
oh then oh
wait this one's mine yeah it's yours and
Tommy got some tonkots some cabbage well
we got udon and tonkots nice for dessert
we've got some cold sweet bean and
glutinous rice balls I took back into
this restaurant 20 years ago and so
we're kind of Chasing The Nostalgia a
little bit this is nice
is that good guys you like that
yeah
hold on hold on arigato
[Music]
all right guys have you ever been on a
ferris wheel before no no
I'll open it oh Isn't that cool I see
tons of clay you guys you can see the
ocean over there this is fun though
right yeah it's fun it's okay
this park is a memorial to 26 Martyrs
who were crucified when Christianity was
banned in Japan in the 1600s after a
failed peasant Uprising Christianity and
foreigners were banned throughout all of
Japan and this area was a hotbed of
Christianity with some areas being
majority Christian and those people were
murdered or forced to denounce their
faith lots of them were murdered
this is Saint Lorenzo Ruiz he was a
Filipino missionary here and he was
tortured many many times in an attempt
to get him to renounce his faith and he
refused to do so and eventually was
killed
hey look at this these are Christian
samurai sword hilts this is a 340 year
old sign offering a reward for any
information that leads to the discovery
of Christians
yeah relics from the mother's bodies
here
oh yeah that's a bit of his arm
was that a bit heavy
was it interesting though
refreshing
all right
well me and Nathan are kind of hot and
sticky we think we need baths you need a
bath
let's see
now listen you can't get into this bath
until you clean yourself what oh here
come with me come with me this is a
Japanese bath and you don't get into
Japanese baths if you're dirty before
you get in the tub you've got a shower
that makes no sense and look and look
there's a seat here with the shower you
sit down in the shower now rinse your
hair rub rub rub all right now that
we're clean it's bath time time to get
in the open
foreign
now taking a shower before you get into
the bathtub might seem a little strange
but there's a good reason for it the
Japanese recycle their bath water and if
you're going to be reusing the same bath
water over in Oregon you don't want it
to be gross so bathtubs in Japan are
treated like a hot spring or a spa and
not as a place to scrub yourself not a
bad way to unwind after walking all day
all right guys get your shoes on well
tonight's gonna have a special night for
me I'm meeting some really close friends
of mine and getting to introduce them to
my kids when I was about 20 years old I
served my church as a missionary for two
years here in Kyushu and I met some
wonderful people during that time and
some of those friends from over 20 years
ago are going to meet us for dinner
hi
all right check out this restaurant this
is fancy
this is a very Japanese restaurant good
part okay
hey
look at their sausage they're Sashimi
french fries oh they they got your
number
goodbye
oh look at this how pretty this is
oh yeah
he goes to got some raw fish here a
little sashimi
all right we're doing another course
here this is this is amazing food now me
and Becca have learned a thing or two
we've realized that we can't take our
children to nice restaurants unless we
reserve a private room we have to keep
the chaos contained you're under the tip
get out go sit up we're gonna use Shabu
Shabu oh fun it's kind of like Korean
Hot Pot okay
[Music]
all right we got some wagyu beef here
delicious was amazing that was a piece
that was a feast
[Music]
thank you guys for coming all right
we'll see you guys tomorrow
you like this this is a fun restaurant
this was so fun this was amazing
get over this way over this way I saw
him
oh well it's been a lovely day but we
have got to get these kids to bed I will
see you guys in the morning
the finest baked goods 7-Eleven has to
offer Japanese peanut butter sandwiches
are the best Now peanut butter is
amazing isn't it
they're dumb they're two pancakes with
butter and maple syrup in there I just
go to I figured they'd taste like a
leftover pancake no these are really
fluffy and fresh
oh this is the uh the Mochi donut to
share that with Mama
um that's chewy all right guys we gotta
leave for church here in a few minutes
so everyone get ready
I gotta turn the lights off with this
remote
there you go so crazy
there call the cops
amazing
we made it to church time to turn the
camera off I'll see you guys a little
bit right here our ride's here come on
Well church was fun we had a great time
and I got to see some old friends we're
gonna get together with how much people
from church and kind of hang out a
little bit oh
oh so good
we're in the city of Isaiah
I lived here for eight months this is
very nostalgic
hey Tommy
oh my goodness look at this
whoa you gotta eat the dessert first
oh good job
yeah this is a tea made from barley
do we even know where our children are I
know where that one is oh there's one
uh Jacob just fell off the slide oh got
a little Mark forehead
this has been awesome the boys have been
making new friends we've been seeing old
friends eating food talking it's been a
wonderful day
all right when you're in Japan you've
got to give presents right oh Miyake is
yo we brought some presents for you guys
all right here so Alaska chocolate
[Music]
you got to be careful giving gifts to
Japanese people because if you give too
nice of a gift that starts a gift war
and you will lose I gave their father a
Leatherman Tool and he thought that was
too nice of a gift and so he got me a
custom-made hunting knife
[Music]
it's awesome me and Becca wrote a kid's
book a number of years ago and one of
the kids both has Miss wujiwada in it so
we decided to give her a copy of the
book oh
oh nice
ready to eat
one okay isn't that a lovely sandwich
oh my goodness
[Music]
well guys I think it's time to shoot off
some fireworks yeah you gotta blow some
stuff off
okay yes
yes
this is great I'm one of these okay
everyone grab one
there you go
this is
well guys we made it back to Nagasaki
and the kids are exhausted but we've had
such a lovely time I'm gonna put the
camera down I'm gonna see you guys
tomorrow morning
me and Tommy are out hunting and
Gathering again
we got some breakfast sandwiches for me
and Mom
yeah sure here
a load of pastries but also look at
these grapes
it's like a BLT with eggs yeah this
apple juice is so good this pastry's got
bamboo shoots in it
that's actually really good but it's
Savory it's not sweet at all you guys
ready to go do some fun stuff today do
you want to go to Ninja Village
please
all right guys we're here at ninja
Village in Saga prefecture
the boys are gonna start their ninja
training Tommy you can do it
[Music]
oh
you guys look awesome one two three
now if you guys watch our travel videos
a lot you know we've got a bit of a soft
spot for local kitschy sort of
activities this is so right up our alley
ninjas
into the Shadows
[Music]
the sword it's got the raincoat made out
of grass that's like a lady sword yeah
it's like a tiger claw see and those are
shoot again
that's Samurai armor look at those
here take a left only all the frogs
you got him
assault
oh
they'll get splinters in your butt
I hear a lot of parents say I want to
travel but I'm going to wait until my
kids are old enough to appreciate it and
what I found is the kids do appreciate
travel they just appreciate different
things than we do well we get really
excited about the history and the art
and the culture things like this drive
them Wild
this is ninja practice
[Music]
high five
that's cool
in the old days before they had heat and
electricity this is what they would do
here's the kitchen
throwing stars
Nathan do you know what that is
that's a calculator
see the families had different symbols
these are all the different crests of
the different samurais there's a ninja
this is this is the ninja star range
[Music]
you ready to go to the haunted house
it's fine
so much
oh yeah that's good
like he's chopping up someone's legs
[Music]
that has to be one of the lamest haunted
houses I've ever seen and it was the
most fun I've ever had in a haunted
house it's all about the company you
keep you know that
okay
[Music]
go go for it go look for the Ninja
Turtle star
[Applause]
[Music]
was that cool
they carry you around to one of these
the cannon
it's got trap doors in secret places
the Secret Door
what
this one oh
man
what is this give me mine
this is Samurai house isn't this pretty
oh
[Music]
what is that
your ninja clothes in there okay guys
did you enjoy ninja muta yeah yeah
bye-bye
you guys get back there
oh look
you guys hungry
we got zarus the bull for Jacob yeah I
ordered some oyakodom
oyakadon means parent and child on Rice
because it's eggs and chicken
probably like your food
oh like the uh
the next day
this is a lot of fun all right it's
starting to rain on us I think we better
get some umbrellas you don't wear
raincoats in Japan it's too humid
now because everyone uses umbrellas all
the stores have umbrella stands outside
so you don't bring your drippy umbrella
inside
one of the cream cheese Nathan loves
that one all right that's a lot of foot
push the button
we've definitely found a Groove here in
Nagasaki got egg sandwiches fresh baked
bread and fresh fruit
[Music]
that's blueberry yogurt
not mommy's sandwich
it's pretty good fruit huh
oh now that breakfast is over we've got
to pack up and get checked out take your
bags outside guys
foreign
all right guys we're back here in
Fukuoka and we're checking back into the
Oriental hotel for just one night
because we want to go see a baseball
game let me see your umbrella
the drips from getting in the hotel
oh look at that mommy you got your
umbrella
do you want some Ramen okay let's please
all right we're gonna get some Ramen
head over
here
here let's just send some of those
oh I love real Japanese ramen and gyozas
they're so good
one thing I love about Japan is there's
no tipping if you try to tip it'll just
cause problems don't do it there's no
tipping in Japan it saves you so much
money when you're on vacation
right
Fukuoka is home to one of Japan's best
major league baseball teams so we're
here at the Fukuoka Pepe Dome and we're
gonna see the soft big Hawks play me and
Mommy went to games here wet vacuum is
the fuku kadai Hawks
want that yeah
that looks pretty good you got a plushie
yep
okay
all right
[Music]
all right we're watching the Fukuoka
softbanks Hawks play the true Nichi
dragons
a foul ball just came over and hit Tommy
in the head a little bit
[Music]
yeah we just squirted our boys this
Stadium's awesome they actually have a
retractable roof so they can open and
close it depending on the weather
know that
oh look at that do you want seaweed on
your pizza this pizza's got mustard and
potatoes you like the pizza
that's the game we won
[Music]
all right
foreign
get some kids to bed I'm gonna see you
guys in the morning
once you go get your tray oh look at
this it's a wall of donuts might have to
take this little guy
oh you're gonna grab some
this is probably the best breakfast
buffet I've ever seen at a hotel this is
amazing they have a wall of donuts I'm
excited to try my breakfast hamburger
dang that is a really good burger
a red bean paste with
[Music]
you
you want to try some corn soup
you like that
all right
all right guys we're leaving Fukuoka and
heading to the city of Kumamoto so we
got to get our bags out of here and go
all right we made it to the city of
Kumamoto
and first thing we're gonna do is go get
a haircut we got some furry boys
come on
barber shop and this is the Ito family
these are my very good friends and they
used to cut my hair back 24 years ago
right
congrats to see you I told the boys you
could get cool haircuts here in Japan
and so they've been letting their hair
grow out for like three months because
you can shoot in there yeah you're
looking good Tom
is that neat
the first shave buddy
some knife that's a knife one slight
move and you'll die
got a hot towel on an egg
yeah
you like it I feel like I'm being nude
uh you got a good head Nathan
okay
you are looking good I think it's
Jacob's turn
hey Jacob you wanna you want a haircut
just like Tommy yeah Tommy what do you
think you love your haircut
yeah you like that you're looking good
bud
yeah look at that base
all right those chairs are comfy aren't
they you like your hair guide yeah
you ready
yeah
what do you think Jake does daddy need a
shave too
much
you're looking good buddy
um
that is nice even got my ears shaved
they were getting a little hairy
you like that oh yeah that's a lot of
hair
look at that that is a whole bunch of
good looking right there what do you
think you love your haircuts yep
exactly how I want every time a friend
comes by they put their hand print on
the shock you want to put your hand
print on the shop yeah
okay now I see that sticker right there
and press hard and don't let it smear
yeah there we go that is a nice one all
right that was a good one
it's in here well me and Becca are
staying at a hot spring spa near a
volcano tonight so we need to get going
but we got a lot of stuff and a lot of
kids so we're bringing two cars
[Music]
we booked a room in a Japanese rocon
that's like a fancy Spa bed and
breakfast
this is gorgeous and look at here's the
bathroom and out here
your own private Hot Springs bath and
you get to look over this private Garden
the traditional rope called the yugata
and they wear them here at these rocon
spas
what's up
so it looks good on you babe because
putting on the complimentary socks dizzy
yay all right guys time for dinner
Japanese rocons are more like Spas than
bed and breakfasts and they typically
include extravagant meals
these are your own little barbecues and
they've got some really good beef and
vegetables this is a soup that's warming
up and then over here you've got the
sashimi and those little green things
Jacob is that pretty cool to eat your
own little barbecue
oh
this is a Kumamoto Del Casey it's raw
horse meat or basashi
it's good high quality Versace can cost
you well over a hundred dollars a pound
yeah
do you like that that's really good
isn't it we ordered kids meals for the
three boys this came as part of the kids
meal
s like the tail you want to try the tail
[Music]
is the most amazing beef steak I've ever
had in my life
this is dessert
that is the best cantaloupe I've ever
had
that is delicious isn't it really good
melon I forgot how much I like this
[Music]
well now that we're all fed I think it's
time to soak in our private Hot Springs
what do you think baby you like this I
love it yeah this is nice
well good morning boys how did you like
sleeping in the futons
[Music]
okay
we're gonna wear our indoor jackets to
breakfast I believe these are called
hunt tens
this egg right here is raw and we're
gonna crack it in here so we're gonna
get eggs and bacon well check out this
fancy breakfast we got fish row we got
fish cakes smoked fish a salad I don't
know what that is roots maybe yogurt I
think this fish row is a little bit of a
regional delicacy here in gyushu
okay
that wasn't my favorite
that looks pretty good
there you go buddy
these meals are kind of interesting
because there's so many things I don't
know what they are and a lot of them I
don't even know what they're made out of
so you're just kind of popping things in
your mouth and seeing what happens if
you have any idea what that is no
oh yeah
Good Egg
well we have a lot of sights here we
want to do today so we hired a taxi for
an entire day
you know where our first stop is
we're going up to the top of this
volcano look at all the rice field
s
it smells like farts doesn't it you guys
excited to look down the mouth of a
volcano
these concrete bunkers are for people to
take shelter if an eruption occurred you
can see there's hard hats in there
that right there is the mouth of an
active volcano is this is Mount also one
of several active volcanoes here in
Kyushu that cloud is full of sulfur
dioxide and other poisonous gases so if
it blows this way they'll set off an
alarm and we gotta run for it you can't
see it because of the smoke but down
there is a Green Lake full of acid
that's the volcano disaster alert Center
you can see there's safety workers
around waiting to get people out of here
if needs to be
the crater has this faint smell of burnt
silver
yeah there's sulfur on the rocks
Thomas you've now been to the top of an
active volcano and looked down its
throat what do you think of that
this is a Shinto Tori or gate the Shinto
religion is a deep part of the Japanese
culture and we are going to go up to a
Shinto shrine
at The Shrine there's a little offering
box that people throw coins in and you
make a prayer and you ring the bell to
get the attention of the Gods these
shrines are usually erected on some sort
of natural feature That's Unique there's
a cave a river or a beautiful mountain
the locals will build a shrine to the
spirit that lives there
thank you
this beautiful natural Arch is why they
built the shrine here
it might look like people have left
their garbage here but those are
offerings those are bottles of alcohol
and tea and that's a bag of rice
see here people have left coins as an
offering to the spirit
oh see that that's a Japanese murder
hornet
if you don't know what a murder Hornet
is it's a Japanese psychotic wasp the
size of a hummingbird
supposed to raise your hand when you
cross the road
there you go
oh
let's go get some lunch oh
who wants meat noodles you want
croquettes
there's four things
does anyone want Curry
Okay who wants chicken on Rice
here's beef noodles do you like your
noodles
so this right here is a croquette it's
like mashed potatoes with meat and
vegetable formed into a ball and deep
fried
we're just getting ready to leave and
Nathan found a five dollar coin on the
ground and turned it into the store
owners so they gave the boys all ice
cream for being good honest boys
oh
so this is the takachiho gorge and
normally you can rent both and row boat
all the way up into the gorge and up to
the waterfall but because of all the
rain they're worried about flooding and
they're not running boats today so
that's a little heartbreaking isn't it
that is so cool
yeah that is a very very fat sturgeon
okay everyone gets a bag
pretty
look at this water wheel and they use it
to turn machinery
oh look at that he's got a little trout
see him there's a little trout right in
there
eye gets closed well we had a lot more
plans but unfortunately you can't rent
the boats and go up the gorge half the
viewing platform is closed for
construction and the fishing is closed
for some reason but we're still having a
great time
well it wasn't on the agenda but Tommy
really wants to check out this aquarium
oh
oh my goodness look at that that's a
akame it's a Japanese barramundi
that's a Japanese catfish
is that an axolotl yeah that's an
axolotl wrong it's an
you guys having fun yeah
fine
they're like Cheetos but they're sweet
another good huh
we're back in the city of kubamoto we're
gonna check in the cando hotel
oh look at this I gotta tell you what
guys the exchange rate is so fabulous
this hotel was so cheap I think it was
uh 150 for this room I couldn't stay at
a Holiday Inn for that much money you
ready
all right love you babe
hunt for a Samurai helmet
this is all pigeons too someone's turned
these entire two homes into adjoining
pigeon coops full of hundreds of pigeons
I think this is it
these are Japanese higonokami knives
would you want a pocket knife like this
yeah
yeah this is it
oh look at that Lost Boy
oh Kitty
it's like it's like a samurai hat I'm
gonna buy I'm gonna buy those I can put
those to use
Arigato thank you very much
well Tommy got a pocket knife I got two
really awesome old Japanese hatchets and
a samurai hat yeah
hey family
well everyone is tired so I'm gonna go
out and get food for the family my
instructions were something simple and
not crazy
well looks like there's a show 10 up
ahead we're gonna go check that out a
shotan's just a covered Road that's open
only to pedestrian traffic it's kind of
like a mall
tofu Burger I got a bunch of hamburgers
I got a feeling that's gonna hit the
spot
are you guys in the mood for hamburgers
here is the kids cheeseburger
and you guys want french fries and me I
have got the fried tofu Burger yeah this
is gonna be a wild ride I'm looking
forward to that fortunately
that was pretty good I got something
called a milk cream
there is a watery milkshake you guys
want to go check explore a little bit
yeah you want to go over here and play a
little bit
no
no oh
that was so easy
look at that Jake yeah
[Music]
guys you want some ice cream
these are really good we should bring
some home to Mommy tell me check this
out it's a waffle here
the ice cream filled waffle Jacob these
are called shoe creams we call them
cream puffs in the U.S dig you like
those those are really good those are
mommy's favorite this nice soft eggy
pastry with a custard inside
um
well it is late and we have a big day
ahead of us tomorrow so I'm gonna put up
this camera I'll see you guys in the
morning
good morning everybody do you want
breakfast and you know it pat your belly
grab your room
hey Buddies
my Japanese Taco here
not a bad free Hotel breakfast at all
you guys like your breakfast
well despite the rainy weather me and
the family are gonna go check out
Kumamoto Castle
this is a famous Samurai named
katokiomassa he fought on The Winning
Side in the great Japanese Civil War and
because of that he was awarded Kumamoto
prefecture and so he built Kumamoto
castle and kumoto Castle is considered
one of the top three castles in Japan
see where they're doing all this
construction and the wall of the castle
was damaged that was from the earthquake
here in Kumamoto seven years ago oh wow
there's a lot of damage from the
earthquake
see right there
amazing
I think that's the toilet look at this
guys
he's dancing with the
thing with the toilet would shoot the
guns out
I'm an old man
see
me
here boys hop in so we're gonna be
eating okonomiyaki and Yaki soba which
are two of our favorite foods is that
your melon soda that just is really good
actually
[Music]
give me your plate
no it's a sweet sauce
so this is okonomiyaki it's an
unsweetened pancake with meat and ginger
and cabbage it's really good the biggest
having Yaki Silva It's stir-fried
noodles with beef and cabbage
everywhere on the front
well we've had a good time in Kumamoto
but we're leaving the island of Kyushu
and headed to the city of Hiroshima it's
only a two-hour ride by Bullet Train
welcome to Hiroshima
[Music]
three sets of bunk beds
I can tell you it could be really hard
to find hotel rooms it'll fit a family
of five but here in Japan we've had no
problem and this place was less than 200
a night Fukuoka is playing Hiroshima
well everyone's tired so I am gonna go
get dinner and run a few errands
all right I'm trying to find a really
fun Japanese kids book for the boys this
is a fun little book gig again no
quintro and Doraemon and of course it's
Japanese so you read it right to left so
this is the front of the book this is
the back
beckon the boys wanted pizza so we're
gonna try out this Italian restaurant
hey family SoftBank Hawks are kicking
some butt so guys this one's a cheese
pizza and that one's a Roma pizza I like
it yeah I'm enjoying the pizza but it
tastes like octopus oh oh oh
and that's the game man they trounced
Hiroshima all right guys we gotta get
kids to bed it is late I will see you
guys in the morning
we have a beautiful full day here in
Hiroshima and the first thing we're
gonna do is go to miyajima Island
it looks like the deer's truck in it
oh you like that huh
there you go there's one tick on we're
here at miyajima or Mia Island and
there's wild deer all over the island
barely got off the ferry and there's
just deer everywhere in this park
I think
getting a bag of roasted chestnuts and
sweet potato ice cream this is the
Chestnut roaster
oh sounds good remember Mommy gave you
life she doesn't have to share
what do you think of the roasted
Chestnut you like that roasted potatoes
you like them it's good
look at those oh those are pretty cute
oh my goodness
look at that I bought a couple replica
samurai swords for our thumbnail and
because most adult men are looking for
an excuse to buy a sword
yeah look at this boys you got this yet
[Music]
you're gonna put on your dear ninja
socks so you gotta get your big toe in
there
there you go your ninja sandals those
are called geta
these souvenir shops are kitschy but
they're kind of fun
well the big thing out here miyajima is
the Tory in the water in about two hours
the tides will be out and you can
actually walk out to the gate
grilled pork roast beef grilled tongue
chicken
you got that
beef tongue
this is actual pup yeah it's a cow's
tongue sliced up tastes good
[Music]
good morning
yeah
boy that's one of the more Japanese
things I've seen right now
one of the deer came up to Nathan and
bit his arm and grabbed a shish kebab
but then I threw
a bob
[Music]
yeah it's nice to sit down
I'll see you in a little bit okay
oh the lion is huge so me and Tom are
gonna walk down
okay
you're gonna hate going downhill by the
end of this
me and Tommy are racing mommy back to
the bottom
[Applause]
oh that's pretty hey are you guys okay
hey look at Tom there's the mountain we
climbed
boys hop in
yep yeah you should be just fine I will
do
me and Tommy wanted to see the museum in
the historic sites but Mom and the other
boys are too tired so they're gonna head
back to the hotel and uh we're gonna do
a little fodder Sun time
this is the building before and after
so they're like almost snapped in real
life
check out that building it's one of the
few in the area that survived the blast
so this is the gembaku Dome
so this right here is where the first
atomic bomb was ever dropped on human
beings the bomb blew up about 600 meters
right above this spot
people
you notice that a lot of the girls are
in kimonos that's because the Summer
Festival just started tonight I think
we'd go check it out
here in these festivals they open the
streets to pedestrians only and they set
up these stalls and it's just a great
time everyone stays open until about
midnight
there you go yeah yeah
they're little candy apples and Candy
strawberries
strawberry covered in Jolly Rancher
candy
is
it's like a pancake with chocolate in
there
downtown Hiroshima almost all of the
neighborhoods look like this they're
just jam-packed with people from all
over the area stalls everywhere I think
me and Tommy could have easily stayed up
to midnight exploring all of that but
our legs are smoked I was tired before
we even started walking
yeah
those mod cities usually involve massive
parades and fireworks and other really
cool things
you're so cute
[Applause]
that was fun but you might have made the
right decision by staying home my body
hurts get your shoes on everyone we're
going to dinner
because you got a kid's meal he gets to
pick one toy
oh all right well that's perfect look at
that meal there you go hey babe what do
you think of that burger
there you go Tom you got some steak that
looks good buddy
we have got to catch a train at 6 20 in
the morning tomorrow morning oh
I'll see you guys in the morning
[Music]
well guys we made it to the city of
Osaka
we met up with my good friend Mr Sato
here and it's Sunday so he's gonna take
us to church with his family and then
we're gonna go over to his house and
hang out
well we arrived just in time for church
so I'm gonna put the camera down and
I'll see you guys in a little bit what
do you guys think did you understand
anything
oh he had a good time but getting up at
5am is catching up to me
tired
uh here we are
Tommy when he was just a little guy
here
thank you for picking us up
and then you cook it and then you cook
it
the Sato family are making gyozas and
karage
deep fried
chickens are dumplings I'm making them
too
you got Japanese curry rice fried
chicken gyllises and salad
I'm singing
hey boys boys gotta clean up hey boys
grab your plates
Nathan do you like it me and Taki are
here we served missions together for our
church 24 years ago it was a fun time
but we better get going back home the
kids are tired
come on boys say goodbye
here my cousin
oh there we go
oh okie dokie
all right here's the bedroom got a
little balcony out here
oh we got video consoles and
video games there are more beds down
here look at that they're all good sized
ones too
oh my goodness my sons are now getting
to experience the best video game ever
made by man
is this the best rental house we've ever
had yeah yeah yep
dear Luke Nichols we have Osaka's famous
cheesecake in our refrigerator ooh thank
you look at that I got Headroom
oh
my goodness that is an amazing looking
cheesy yeah hide that one yeah kids
don't appreciate that stuff all right
guys we're getting kids to bed and
tomorrow we're going to be exploring
Osaka so I'm gonna turn off the camera
I'll see you in the morning all right
guys we got breakfast
having a special meal for breakfast
isn't exactly a thing in Japan so
traditionally people just eat leftovers
from the night before
I wanted to do something just me and
Nathan today and I asked him what he
wanted to do and what did you answer
shopping spree
you want to try that you gotta do this
okay what she's gonna show you all you
do is try to pull this back to your
cheek
you did really well
yeah
yeah got my name up on the board
foreign that was super fun
okay
[Applause]
would that be good for me buddy
that is awesome
yeah Gator is awesome
look at that yeah looking good Nathan
hey look at these These are little
catfish oh you see so
give it a pull yeah
oh let me see your awesome shirts
all right cool come on everyone in
oh my goodness this is an entire floor
of them all dedicated to Pokemon stuff
the kids are going bonkers
[Music]
yeah look at that Pokemon cafe they have
a Pokemon cafe where they have all
Pokemon themed food the kids really want
to go eat there but they are full for
the entire week you definitely need
reservations to get in apparently it's
the most exclusive restaurant we've
tried to eat at so far on this trip
it's an axolotl or they say in Japanese
and ubawuba
guys well the kid's got a bunch of
Pokemon toys and a bunch of packs of
Pokemon cards for their friends back
home
yeah everyone everyone's gonna have one
ah it's like Dakota songs I'll eat the
cabbage
[Music]
you guys like your food it's good huh
that was good it's gonna be an easy one
I can see
all right guys we're gonna check out
Osaka Castle
yeah you've probably seen the sign about
there's little TV displays in the castle
of all these historical events but
they're so low I can barely see them
all right the boy's gonna try on some
Samurai armor like five years ago
[Music]
the tallest hat ever
you end up using a lot of cash here in
Japan and ATMs are a little bit of a
problem
a lot of these ATMs do not have 24-hour
service and are even closed on weekends
so make sure you keep a reserve of cash
in your pocket luckily Japan is super
safe so carrying around lots of money in
your pocket it's perfectly fine
there that's kushikatsu that's a type of
deep fried vegetables and meats on a
stick kushikatsu was invented here in
the shinsekai district of Osaka so a lot
of these restaurants serve kushigatsu
so back in the boys heard a good time we
had this morning and they want to try
out the archery and I want to see if I
can get Becca into one of those biker
girl jackets
come on Becca it's got a tiger and a
dragon I like this one with the uh the
skull kimono here oh look it gets
awesomer inside oh wow
Born Free Die Free yes boys what do you
think is this the coolest jacket mom's
ever had
yeah Jacob do you like the Godzilla one
what do you see oh dang that's awesome
[Music]
that is pretty styling Tom
are those
[Music]
Puffy's shoulderness
when we went before it was the best one
Tommy let me see it
oh my that is a bold statement I love it
Jake you know that fits you better than
I thought that sounds great you see your
Godzilla oh yeah yeah you guys are
looking sticky
oh
is the archery place
[Music]
oh Tommy
hey guys was that fun yeah all right you
guys want to go do a shooting range you
guys ready
oh
nothing yay
mom you are good at that look at that
arigato
all right guys we're gonna have
something called kushikatsu
is it asparagus
[Music]
oh they look like eggplant to me oh
sweet potato I think of Ginger is good
here you go here's your Ramen this is
ramune It's a traditional Japanese soda
and it tastes a little bit like a spider
is 7UP how do you like the fried Lotus
root what Rebecca what did you think of
your first kushikatsu it's good I liked
it it's very nice
I think we're gonna go to the top of
that Tower
all right guys we're on the roof with
the how to cook 300 it's a large
Observatory Tower here in Osaka or
somewhere do you see it
Yeah okay or not it was hard to video up
there because it was so dark but it was
cool
well we made it back to the apartment
but I need to run a few errands me and
Tommy are going fishing tomorrow and I
need to go get some food from the
supermarket so Becca's all taken care of
well me and Tommy are gone all right
Mama we'll be back with food
octopus balls spaghetti barbecued
chicken
uh he's a beef croquette
oh look at those fruit sandwiches those
look good yogurt drinks oh I love those
this is called yummy milk yummy milk
that looks good you want peanut butter
sandwiches yes
I don't think Becca wants beans in the
cereal do you
know melon flavored kitkats wow are
those mecons
oh oh yeah we're getting some meat cones
I don't care what the price is
it's a yakisoba dog what
[Music]
well guys it's late we've got a big
adventure planned for tomorrow I'm gonna
put the camera down I'll see you in the
morning
[Music]
all right Thomas let's go well me and
Tom are gonna go catch a train to Nagoya
Japan we're gonna meet a guy to go
fishing for catfish
that's fast
me and Tommy see if we made it to Nagoya
[Music]
today
well five years ago when me and Tommy
were in Kyoto mazuki-san took us fishing
and we had an amazing time
[Music]
so you come
guys we stopped here at the convenience
store and masayuki-san has picked up
some bread we're gonna catch some carp
for Todd
yo I got all the
SE
let's go can I go over there we're
checking little pieces of white bread on
this pile of carp right there trying to
see if any will come up and eat it I'm
getting a few of them slurping it up
here and there I'm gonna see if we can
get one to bite our hook now
I'm ready oh good good cast oh he's in
it now he's it yeah really really he's
on there he's on there
don't let him
set up pretty nice isn't that's a nice
fish
oh
good job Tom
yeah I like that
that is your first Japanese car visited
yeah put him back in the net there
okay bye-bye bread good job
how mad your mom will be if you don't
come back
oh
I got catfish
yeah look at him he's like he's like
it's like an eel
just caught a catfish on a spinner bait
look at that he just inhaled a spinner
bait
see look at it his mouth looks like a
flathead and then the body is like an
eel they're like a small version of a
Wells catfish yeah for only four oh so
Wells catfish have the six whiskers and
this one has the four yeah he's got no
spine on his desk yeah that is a
Japanese catfish you look at that eel
body
and lots of slime
but he is a predator he nailed that spin
bait right underneath that bridge
you know I've caught catfish before on
lures accidentally but I think that's
the first time I've caught a catfish on
a lure when I was targeting catfish look
at him oh he just ate it he just hold on
to that Tom
yeah get him you got him okay oh he got
him you got him
oh look at that
this is a good sized car that's a
healthy carp
he looks smaller in the water but now
he's getting up here he's he's good I
flipped the Bale
is that bigger than
getting bigger
oh he looks like maybe eight pounds
eight
there is a big bullfrog sitting on that
ladder right on that ladder big old
bullfrog after World War II the U.S
tried to help rebuild Japan and someone
got the bright idea to bring bullfrogs
so the Japanese could have frogs to eat
and of course they had to introduce
crawfish so the bullfrogs would have
something to eat so now there's crawfish
and bullfrogs all over Japan and nobody
eats bullfrogs or crawfish here because
that's a weird Louisiana thing but they
are delicious I love them he's lazy yeah
lazy and chill though
get that rod
[Music]
yeah don't let the lion touch the fence
that one's Genki
I think the other one was a little
bigger but this one was definitely the
most feisty that's sayonara carved song
Thomas how many carb is that
hold it yeah
look at my sunglasses I lost my
prescription sunglasses in the water but
a carp hit him came up and went and
nipped him
look at that job
he got he broke the line your line
touched the wall again bud
oh he's gonna come back for seconds he's
cocky now look at that
oh you got him still got him yeah keep
that belly up against that fence there
you go
okay guys I give him some slack
s yeah
Mazda Yuki sounds telling me about
fishing for Japanese barramundi and look
at the lure they use
and uh it's about two hundred dollars if
this gets caught in a tree you're gonna
go swim for it
oh there's one right there see up
against the wall
little baby tilapia right there
oh wait a minute
here keep his head in the water keep his
head
there you go oh that's a chunky one this
is my first tilapia I've ever caught on
a rod and reel my first Japanese tilapia
fish you tell me you want to get a
picture with him
nice okay
okay
hold it up oil hit one two release these
grippers
we caught like four tilapia two of them
big we caught like five or six koi and
we caught a catfish it's not bad at all
we had a good day
you'll always make it interesting it's
always fun if you're ever in Japan you
want to go fishing give them a call
okay I'll see you next time thank you
thank you
[Music]
well I've got a little boy who's up way
past his bedtime I smell like fish and
we need to get to bed I'll see you guys
in the morning all right guys come up
come up come up we're going
we're on the outskirts of Kyoto City
we're at the bamboo Park it's a massive
Park just covered in bamboo forest well
apparently there's this whole network of
trails with playgrounds and parks and
ponds but it's closed on Wednesdays
big play so we're just gonna go on other
trails
now in Kyoto near arashiyama there's a
nationally famous Bamboo Grove that
everybody goes to and it's really
beautiful but it's packed with tourists
and there's so many people you're not
allowed to get off the path this is much
bigger more natural and there's nobody
here and you're allowed to actually go
in the forest
well it's a tradition that when little
boys are growing up around Jacob's age
they take a traditional Japanese photo
where they wear a ugata and a samurai
sword so we're gonna do that with Jacob
well babe did we get some cute photos
the kids are ready to go and this lovely
gentleman just offered us a ride
a very nice man just doing something to
help a guest in this country out
follow Tommy
all right this is the monkey Park in
arashiyama check it out we got monkeys
oh man
it is these monkeys are pretty chill but
they are still monkeys and they just
might bite your ear off so you know
heads up on that
beautiful view of Kyoto in the
surrounding areas
[Applause]
just go and put it like that like there
so they can reach it
[Music]
there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go babe
is that good it's refreshing huh
oh
yeah oh that's that's you don't right
there
they got Silverman
all right guys on hot summer days like
this cold buckwheat noodles are the best
this is so many
icy cold noodles dipped in icy cold soy
sauce
I think everyone's a little tired of
walking so we're gonna do a rickshaw
ride
this morning
I can show you
the magic of arashiyama
this Temple's name is
[Music]
see there's the bamboo shoot that's what
you boil and eat what made these bamboos
Mr Ito here is telling us that in just a
few months the bamboo grows to full
height yes and that each one of these
rungs here is a day of growth
[Music]
I asked Mr Ito what he does for fun and
he says his hobbies are going to the gym
this guy's a monster
oh
thank you thank you for running thank
you so much
oh those guys are great that was a hoot
[Music]
we're back in the city of Kyoto and
we're gonna go to the Samurai and ninja
Museum
there's a samurai ninja Museum
[Music]
what do you get oh you got ninja claws
shooter cans commas
hey Jacob
well let's see
yeah
[Music]
all right
Jacob hey put your uh sword up one two
three you don't have to go home but we
can't stay here boys
is that was fun but exhausting I'm tired
I'm so tired as always guys we're gonna
put links in the video description for
all of these different activities
throw Pig house would you like to cuddle
pigs
oh you want a bit of this oh what do you
got there
oh I think he abandoned it you press
them
yeah
all right who wants apple juice Nathan
oh
I'm gonna steepest stairs in the world
oh my goodness that was fun did you have
a good time I did have a good time all
right I think we need to head back to
Osaka it's getting late
[Music]
we made it home we got a bunch of boys
to put to bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
[Music]
well the Santo family said they're going
to come pick us up and we're going to do
a little side seat together I'm really
looking forward to this
well our first stop today is something a
little different we wanted to go to
explore a nearby waterfall so we're just
gonna go do a little hike
oh look at that
it's telling you be careful of murder
Hornets
that was kind of a random diversion but
it was really fun
all right guys we're in the city of nada
foreign
Sonata is famous for all the wild deer
that live around the park and you can
buy the little rice cakes and feed them
you want to feed the deer
okay this is food these are deer sembes
or deer rice crackers and oh my goodness
he knows I got him protect yourself
you want to feed him
oh that is doubled my fingers
Hey guys does this look good kids are a
little hungry so I think we're gonna get
some food here
oh isn't that awesome we got noritama
seaweed sprinkles do you like your
seaweed sprinkles
somebody
this phone I like but the animals
this is one of my favorite Japanese food
broiled eel on Rice of broil deal
pickled radish
that was good
all right we're gonna check out Temple
here this is a Buddhist temple
look at that that's crazy
these Buddhist temples are amazing
they're put together all using joinery
no Nails Fasteners nothing like that
so this is what the temple originally
looked like man it's huge
[Music]
all right guys this is the gateway to a
Shinto Shrine Shinto and Buddhism are
different religions but both are very
popular here in Japan
foreign
Ada is the home to many amazing shrines
and temples and world heritage sites but
we're starting to poop out we've already
done a lot of walking so I think we're
gonna head back to the car
we're just on our way back to Osaka and
sato-san says hey we should stop by
horiology Temple
oh
a traditional Japanese toilet Tommy's
using his first traditional Japanese
toilet
yeah that was awesome
Temple is special because it is supposed
to be the oldest wooden building in the
world we're actually only seeing one
small part of the temple but everyone's
legs are tired and it's raining so we're
going back to the car
foreign
guys we're gonna go to dinner here we're
gonna do some Yaki niku
oh
dude this is Japanese barbecue got a
barbecue right here in the table and uh
we're gonna eat some of the best meat in
the world all right we've got some fat
here
this is the best salad I've had in a
long time
salad dressing on it
ah thanks so much for for taking us
around
it's go time
[Applause]
all right Tommy really wants to go to an
aquarium so we're going to aquarium look
at our little Japanese school kids on
field trip they're so cute aren't they
thank you
[Music]
everybody
yeah
I ate your brothers
[Music]
was that the coolest aquarium you've
ever been to yeah
yeah all right let's go get some food
I'm hungry
hey I got some food for you
this is a malasada it's a Japanese
version of the Hawaiian version of a
Portuguese donut
all right we're taking the kids to a
play area here they're excited
look at this
holy mackerel this is huge
all of these games are about eight cents
a piece to play so it's really cheap
[Music]
shooting
guns oh okay they got a gun range
[Music]
this is a soccer video game
yeah darts comic book room
tennis court
karaoke bar yeah the ice cream for only
80 cents Becca this place is insane have
you seen all they have find find a
roller skate and a helmet that fit you
Nathan's got his entire roller rig to
himself
this building is four stories tall with
full of entertainment and for 15 bucks a
piece we get unlimited use of all the
games and activities for 90 minutes it's
quite a deal
[Music]
get them Jay get him
oh strike
go fast go fast
[Music]
um
dominate was that fun yeah
okay we're back in the shinsekai
district and we're gonna be going to a
restaurant where we can catch and cook
our own fish
[Music]
here we go this is the entire
restaurant's a giant aquarium and you
get to fish for your dinner
[Music]
all right guys
to catch some dinner
this is
that okay
oh
stole it it's School
keep them in the water that means
[Music]
oh
these stole my hook
[Music]
ER
Keep On The Water keep in the water
amazing
oh my goodness
congratulations David you got a tie
that's a pink sebum hey how do you want
it cooked Nathan can we do that yeah we
could do that that's good okay there we
go cook it all right Jake you ready grab
your fishing rod
oh here you got one yeah yeah here pull
them
fishy body there we go
take it with Mama and figure out how you
want them cooked they'll show you
pictures you got one Jake you got one
whoa whoa keep them up find him
there we go yes you got him Jake
[Music]
okay let's go jerk straight up
there we go
[Music]
oh there you go Becca you did it
oh yes perfect
look at that puffer fish look they've
got Maine Lobster spiny Lobster
snails butter clams this place is crazy
look at this
are you guys your fish Jacob
you wanna you wanna eat them
see if I just take a little bit of soy
sauce
[Music]
okay
how was that it was pretty good huh so
here's some flounder sushi
[Music]
[Applause]
The Flounder nuggets are good huh
you like your food
from the pink seabrums
that is so good really good it's really
good
[Music]
that's the horse meat right there
whatever
yeah let's go find him a home right here
in the middle Becca you have a time
very good
it was
okay Becca was that good that was so
good
well thank you guys this is so fun thank
you very much
that was so much fun but today was our
last full day in Japan tomorrow morning
we're getting up early and heading for
the airport so we got a lot of packing
to do a lot of cleanup to do see you
guys in the morning
[Applause]
[Music]
what
makes me feel it to write you this song
[Music]
two hours a day five months in a year oh
I loved you too long
[Applause]
[Music]
I keep asking myself
like are you tired yes but we had a good
time though right we had a great time
well listen I hope you guys enjoyed
watching this video as much as we
enjoyed this trip thanks for watching
don't forget to click subscribe we'll
see you guys next Saturday morning we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]